[Musique]
avec nos julie morin mairesse de
lac-mégantic bonsoir bonsoir
alors comment se porte l'économie de
lac-mégantic huit ans plus tard est-ce
que la reconstruction est complètement
achevé madame morin n'ont pas
complètement cherchait encore un des
fils même mais huit ans plus tard
certains auraient pensé que ce serait
plus rapide mais ça va bien quand même
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en fait le
centre-ville qu'on connaissait avant a
été inaccessible pendant trois ans pour
la décontamination alors il ya eu jeudi
rue une petite exode de c'est à dire
aller les gens se sont installés un peu
auto alors notre centre-ville il encore
de la place pour des projets approuvés
100 % de ce qui devait être construit
qui soit trouvé avant dans le centre
ville et reconstruit
maintenant ce sera un des nouveaux
projets qu'on est en train de déployer
et il ya de la place dans le
centre-ville historique comme on
l'appelle parce que effectivement les
autres projets se sont replacées un peu
autour du périmètre par me nombreux
projets vous avez mis en branle
inauguration aujourd'hui donc du micro
réseau électrique ça quelle importance
cette initiative pour lac mégantic
c'est majeur c'est majeur parce que en
fait vous savez ce qu'on a vécu le 6
juillet 2013
c'est une folie ferroviaire bien sûr
mais dans lequel y avait plus de 7
millions de litres de pétrole brut qui
se sont déversés dans notre centre-ville
dans notre lac alors c'est une tragédie
humaine bien sommet environnemental
également sans précédent donc de se
tourner pour nous voir l'innovation par
les technologies vertes l'énergie
renouvelable s'achète du sens et c'est
cette vision là comporte depuis
plusieurs années depuis le 2014 en fait
et ce projet là vient concrétiser
finalement notre vision ou être un
premier pas vers cette transition le con
qu'on veut qu'on veut mettre de l'avant
pour les prochaines années
et dans le même esprit si on veut il ya
eu une autre annonce importante la
semaine dernière c'est une usine de
bioéthanol c'est quoi ce projet oui en
fait c'est la première usine de ces
réseaux d'énergie en fait donc une terre
procédé qui fait du bioéthanol à partir
de résidus de bois et de résidus
agricoles aussi on parle de deuxième jeu
ération parce que ce sont vraiment ce
qui est laissé dans les champs ou dans
les dans les bois par les producteurs
alors c'est une première usine
entièrement dédié à la france un
objectif qui s'installe dans notre parc
industriel alors encore là c'est
important parce que c'est des paul qu'on
fait on de cette vision au lob mais il
faut attacher des projets et là c'est en
train de se passer
huit ans plus tard donc on en est très
fier oui bon parmi les autres projets la
voie de contournement c'est inévitable
qui on travaille toujours sur ce dossier
là ça devrait être construit on en est
rendu c'est toujours une priorité
j'imagine a totalement totalement pour
plusieurs raisons le bien sûr il ya
encore eu cette courbe et cette pente
qui amène le train vers le centre-ville
le train passe encore et je sais que
certains se surprendre en contre 1 passe
exactement au même endroit encore huit
ans plus tard alors c'est vraiment une
priorité
le gouvernement en est actuellement à
faire les plans et devis via la
compagnie ferroviaire et ils ont engagé
cette édition avec les citoyens qui
seront impactées par les futurs passages
alors que ça s'est fait dans les
dernières semaines donc on y parle de
construction sur les années 2020 2023
je voudrais courir les marins sessegnon
2020 et 3 ça fera dix ans à ce moment
oui et je vous dirais que c'est clair
c'est clair mais j'étais donc on était
près de 50 des jeunes après la tragédie
et 10 au plus tard et j'ai vraiment ces
quelques mois après que une annonce qui
ont été déjà 114 s'était déjà on peut
pour rattraper ces années là alors le
fou regarde en avant est avancée mais
c'est trop long pour avancer ce sont
quoi les enjeux les priorités de lac
mégantic pour les mois qui viennent
quels sont les projets à compléter ben
là je voudrais que ça bouge énormément
on a mis en place des incitatifs à la
construction aussi alors là on voit en
effet une petite part hier en trop pour
des logements parce qu'on est populaire
dans les cantons de l'est a lancé dans
la dernière année alors ça ça nous aide
beaucoup on a beaucoup nouveaux
résidents alors l'on propose le niveau
immobilier de nouveaux terrains des
nouveaux logements et
à l'automne ici on a d'autres logements
à prix abordable qui s'en viennent alors
ça c'est une priorité qui est très
importante
autre chose aussi je voudrais que ces
soucis au niveau commercial où vous
savez on a eu des impacts économiques
importants en fait en lien avec
justement le fait qu'il ya eu un
éclatement de nos zones commerciales il
ya un nouvel axe commercial qui crée
mais il faut qu'il y ait une synergie
alors ça fait partie de nos défis de
créer ce nouveau centre-ville là parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'il y avait le
centre-ville avant qui était une rue
principale comme on le voit dans
plusieurs villes maintenant notre
centre-ville c'est tout un quartier
alors ces deux nouvelles habitudes à
créer c'est ce qu'on s'assure qu'on
travaille le actuellement et on vous
souhaite d'accueillir des touristes pour
dynamiser votre été madame morin je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci et ils seront les bienvenus
bonne soirée bones soir voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit